as president of the security council it
fell to russia to list the un member
states who co-sponsored a resolution
opposing its use of force against
ukraine and calling for an unconditional
withdrawal
botswana viengri
mali the resolution did gain the support
of 11 members of the council with china
india and the united arab emirates
abstaining as expected russia used its
veto power
russia
you can veto this resolution but you
cannot veto our voices
you cannot
veto the truth
you cannot
veto our principles you cannot veto
the ukrainian people
the russian ambassador counted that the
resolution was imbalanced for not
mentioning the shelling of donbass by
the ukrainian government nor the failure
by kiev and the west to implement the
2015 peace deal and he added this
intruder
i will refrain from listing out the
aggressions carried out by the united
states in their history but you are in
no position to moralize
the u.s succeeded in avoiding a chinese
veto with its final version of the
resolution but beijing once again agreed
with russia that the crisis had
developed over time as a result of
nato's disregard for russia's security
and cautioned the security council
any action should be truly conducive to
defusing the crisis rather than adding
fuel to the fire the ukrainian
ambassador accused his russian
counterpart of having no idea what was
in vladimir putin's mind but he did
reaffirm ukraine's commitment and
negotiations even as he despaired for
the safety of his people and i will ask
all of you
to pray
or to meditate if you do not believe in
god
for peace
it's expected that a similar but
non-binding resolution will be
introduced at a special session of the
united nations general assembly where
russia does not have the veto and
already it appears to have the support
of more than 80 of the un's 193 member
states
shia britancy al-jazeera the united
nations